alors céline tram bonsoir à lorlanges si
on a un peu de mal à la reconnaître
non quand elle est habillée mais sa wind
c'est possible alors céline tués ici ce
soir pour ton autobiographie intitulée
ne dis pas que tu aimes ça publié chez
fayard et là on découvre la vraie
katsuni la star du x qui a tourné plus
de 400 films 400 fut plaisait pas
compter
[Musique]
alors moi personnellement ça faisait
très longtemps depuis tout le monde en
parle que j'avais pas interviewer une
star du x et j'imagine que c'est comme
le vélo que ça s'oublie pas je sais pas
non
on va voir alors dans ce livre tu te
mets à nu pour la première fois à propos
de ta période x tu dis on me demande
souvent comment j'ai pu prendre du
plaisir pour la bonne morale il aurait
été plus acceptable de subir donc les
gens peuvent pas admettre ça en fait il
dire ma pauvre ami quoi c'est ce qui est
bizarre c'est que c'est ça qui est
obscène apparemment aux yeux des gens
c'est que on peut parler du porno comme
une épreuve comme une expérience
traumatisante comme comme une expérience
on a été abusé mais dès lors qu'on en
parle comme un plaisir et comme un
joueur assumer ça dérange c'est dommage
quand même ça prouve que j'avance
car dès qu'on parle du porno
comme je vous aime
annabelle maître renard par l'odeur
alléché céline a écrit un livre sur sa
vie de star du porno sous le nom de
katsuni mais on va commencer par le
commencement tu es né sous 6
novembre
alors tu es né en
1979 à lyon ton père professions
libérales tu as hérité de ses origines
vietnamiennes
histoire oui thierry vous avez perdu la
main pour interviewer une star du x il
faut se tortiller sur son siège comme un
collégien en rut et baver un petit peu
alors ton père était très à cheval sur
la discipline j'ai des parents qui ont
éduqué avec des des valeurs très strict
où il faut être le premier à l'école
être sérieux travailleur et ce sont des
très bonnes valeurs d'ailleurs avec mon
caractère forcément ça n'a pas toujours
été très compatibles le catéchisme aussi
oui j'ai été enfant de choeur non voilà
voilà d'où ça vient
laissez venir à moi les petits enfants
non j'ai été très près oui je sais le
truc avec d'un peu émoustillant dont on
enfonce c'était quand il avait le crazy
horse à la télé 31 décembre alors ça ça
tu es moustiques un peu mais pas ça me
mettait un peu mal à l'aise je sentais
que ça va un pouvoir sur sur les hommes
de la famille que ça crée une sorte de y
avait un pouvoir hypnotique et je ne
comprenais pas mais la seule chose que
je comprenais à ce moment là c'est que
ces femmes avaient dû pouvoir ouais mais
c'était peut-être encore très coincé un
tas des lunettes à un appareil dentaire
oulala gg je n'ai jamais été la fille
populaire du lycée c'est très réservé
très timide mais justement il faut se
méfier des gens timides parce que
souvent ça fait un effet de leclerc le
jour où ils se réveillent exactement et
les jours me suis réveillé effectivement
ça fait très chaud alors la seule
diversion à l'époque tu es le karaté et
le jour où tes parents tu interdisent de
participer à une compétition nationale
un truc qui se brisent une sorte de
rupture à ce moment là parce que
justement quand on est adolescent on est
en pleine construction n'a besoin de
repères et souvent le sport constitue
une
une autre éducation par à l'école et à
la famille et à ce moment là ça m'a
vraiment donné confiance en moi et d'un
seul coup à la je me retrouve
dans la possibilité de participer à ce
qui est vraiment un rêve dans ma petite
tête d'adolescente mais évidemment ce
sont les études qui prédomine
effectivement ça a créé une sorte de
rupture avec avec le clan familial à ce
moment là alors côté sexe tu es viergela
l'âge de 19 ans ce qui est assez d'yeux
finalement non je suis dit effectivement
à ce moment là bon ben ali il est
peut-être temps de vivre cette
expérience parce que je veux apprendre
mais ça s'est très bien passé la
première fois c'était pas exceptionnel
parce que finalement comme je n'avais
aucune connaissance de mon corps en fait
tu ressors du plaisir il faut déjà se
connaître soi et être apte en sont
donnés à soi même j'étais complètement
déconnecté de mon corps donc finalement
je pensais qu'ils que j'allais avoir un
énorme déclic et puis je me suis montré
très passive et puis bah ouais moi je me
suis dit c'est pas pour moi en fait ici
la voiture est encore un problème il ya
un jeune homme qui est venue s'asseoir
sur le siège prévu pour dia clair
hélas
non c'est pas le vrai nom c'est le
destin
[Musique]
non tu vas dans une soirée étudiante
et là tu rencontres une dénommée stella
qui est gogo danseuse et elle te fait
découvrir le monde du strip tease et en
juin 1998 et dans vingt ans tu danses
pour la première fois dans un club en
suisse et quelques mois plus tard tu
fait de ton premier strip tease ouais
alors que j'avais dit jamais je n'en
ferai évidemment
c'est souvent comme ça mais j'avais un
vrai besoin d'expérimenter et en fait ce
qui m'amuse et le plus c'est que c'était
complètement à l'encontre de ce que
j'étais de ce que je dégageais puisque
j'avais toujours l'étudiante très
réservée et très discrète c'est très
long les strip-teases suis c'est bien 4
c'était là dessus
[Musique]
c'est un peu la chanson de tous les
cinq ans mais bon port 1999 tuant entre
pour la première fois dans un sex shop
est là et la traîne elle achète un dvd
de gang bang dire c'est que pour toi le
commencement c'est pas le big bang c'est
le gang voilà d'ailleurs tu enchaînes
bientôt ça donne envie bah bien sûr moi
quand on fait quand je vois quelque
chose qui me fascine bien souvent j'ai
envie d'expérimenter oui
non si la partir de mai à partir de 5-6
colle donc c'était dans le cabinet d'un
dentiste c'est ça oui comment ça se fait
alors que je déteste aller chez le nom
tout sauf là ça m'a réconcilié avec le
dentiste avec le dentiste déjà c'est
bien passé c'est ce
qui était plus âgé plus expérimentés et
encore une fois comme c'était comme
c'était un jeu
je me suis vraiment amusé est ce que
pour une femme c'est pascal mieux bien
ce alors un homme avec plusieurs femmes
est considéré comme un roi une femme qui
présentait plusieurs heures on va dire
elles sont très dominés c'est un objet
sexuel mais non en fait une femme qui
fait face à plusieurs zones elle a juste
elle multiplie les plaisirs alors
ensuite il ya un photographe de mode à
grenoble qui te branche sur penthouses
donc le magazine penthouse qu'ils aient
aussi des productions filmé et là tu as
peur de fâcher tes parents oui c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle je ne leur
dit rien moi c'est ça aussi qui fait là
la valeur de l'expérience c'est que ça
reste secret et voilà j'ai un malin
plaisir à voir une double vie entre ma
vie d'étudiante justement et l'adie
souterraine dans le milieu de la nuit
premier casting en juillet 2000 premier
film sous le nom de katsuni
[Musique]
quand tu commences directement par une
double peine et enfin je parle pas de
pâte en plus
mon iphone
ses parents s'aperçoivent toujours de
rien jusque là j'étais pas là je leur
dis rien
c'est terrible c'est tous les jours le
jour où il découvre que t il tant de
stars en fait ils te disent mais c'est
quoi c'est un problème d'argent oui on
peut t'aider je veux toi tu dis non
c'est juste pour le plaisir en fait
absolument et du coup on ne peut pas
contrer un tel argument ouais justement
c'est
et je sais que c'est difficile et
évidemment il ya une pudeur qui
absolument naturel et même nécessaires
au sein d'une famille mais pour moi il
était important de dire non c'est
vraiment mon choix tout va bien et pense
pas que tu sois ouais voilà et personne
n'a d'ampli sur moi tout va bien bien
sûr alors là tu connu une ascension
fulgurante dans le dans le porno tu
tournes avec dorcel colmax beaucoup aux
états unis et de 2000 à 2013 ta vie
c'est vraiment métro porno d'okola tueur
450 ma vie à ce moment là c'est vrai
dans le métro étonné la barre
alors aujourd'hui j'ai fini tu as arrêté
il ya quand même temps il ya déjà cinq
ans ça passe vite mais alors c'est
vraiment une autre vie pour moi ouais
c'est un super bon souvenir je regarde
une bonne nostalgie mais c'est vraiment
mais derrière moi est ce que comme
beaucoup d'ex tard du du x style nikita
bellucci tu déplore en fait que les
associations féministes et l'opinion
publique ne prennent pas assez en compte
le sort des stars du x ou non pas du
tout c'est vrai qu'il y a certaines
formes de discrimination il ya la
malveillance mais il ya aussi beaucoup
de bienveillance ouais ça peut
constituer un handicap que d'avoir un
tel passé sur le plan professionnel mais
ça peut être aussi un atout la preuve
c'est que je suis ici pour en parler
mais quand le tour jules par exemple les
gens forêt oui mais c c'est normal à
partir du moment où on va pas se
plaindre d'être connu et vraiment j'ai
pas du tout à me plaindre parce que les
gens sont super gentils dans le lot il y
aura toujours des personnes qui vont
peut-être pas de faire la différence il
faut être un peu envahissant et certains
ont posté des commentaires un peu un peu
lourd mais en même temps c'est normal
quand pendant 13 ans j'ai vécu les une
image qui repose sur fantasmes et sur le
désir sexuel je ne peux pas me plaindre
aujourd'hui que des gens me disent
s'ils n'ont jamais travaillé chez axa
bien sûr
l'accès
ça fait partie du jeu à toi tu t'en sors
très bien rare martiaux comédie écriture
tu parlais déjà l'écriture quand on t'a
filmer pour paris dernière on regarde
personne longtemps du x
non je commence à les
17 et ignoble non justement j'ai parlé
des fois je parlais des moments durs et
des mous
parce que relancer
salehi dans ta dernière
ça 2005 était devenu pote avec bernard
pivot tu as comme quoi déjà décrite est
un festival ensemble ouais c'est une
super expérience on a parlé de georges
bataille ensemble c'est un très très bon
souvenir on regarde
tu serais libertines oui parce que oui
c'est une soirée de lecture et dans le
thème c'est la littérature érotique
libertines comme vous voudrez du xviiie
siècle donc
mademoiselle est la marraine et je suis
le parrain donc c'est pour ça que nous
formons un couple tout à fait improbable
mais tout à fait charmant je suis
d'accord
ça
[Applaudissements]
après le masque de la
[Musique]
à saint lô
et sympa ah oui à l'oral l1 compte et
ça je le dirai pas et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux